i now want to show you that the standard
algorithm for multiplying numbers can
also be used it's not just limited to
base 10 it can also be used frankly can
be used at any base but we're going to
do it in base two and base two is
especially fun because you essentially
have to only know your multiplication
tables through one so you just have to
know that zero times zero is zero one
times zero is zero and that one times
one is one and then you're ready to go
you're ready to multiply in base two so
let's do that so let's say we have let's
take
let's say we take
nine so let's see nine is going to be
one eight
zero fours
zero twos
and
one so this is nine right over here
represented in base two
and let's say we were to multiply that
times let's say we would multiply that
times seven so we should obviously if we
know our multiplication tables we should
get 63. so seven is one actually i'm
gonna put a zero and the seven would be
one one one but that that's a little bit
boring so let's let's instead do
let's do
nine times five which we know should be
45 so this is one
four
no twos and one one so four plus one is
going to be five so this is nine times
five and we're doing it in base two
so once again same algorithm and
actually before i do it i encourage you
just pause the video and try to use the
same algorithm that you've used for for
base 10 multiplication use the same
algorithm here and let's see if we
actually do get that 9 times 5 is forty
five
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it
let's work through it together so let's
start right over here
in the ones place so we multiply one
times one is one one times zero is zero
one times zero is zero one times one is
one
then we can go
to the two's place
and since we're multiplying all this
times the two's place we can throw a
zero right over here but of course zero
times each of these is just going to be
a bunch of zeros so we you know zero
times one is zero zero times zero zero
zero times zero zero zero times one is
zero so i really didn't have to write
that but i'm just doing it so that you
see that i'm using the standard
algorithm
and then
we go to the fours place
and since we're in the fourth place
let's put some zeros here so zero zero
we're essentially figuring out we're
essentially talking about a certain
number of fours not a certain number of
ones so one times that is just going to
be one
zero
one
and now we're ready to add
now we are ready to add
so one plus a bunch of zeros is one a
bunch of zeros
but that's going to be one one plus a
zero bunch of zeros is one
zeros and one and we're done and
obviously if we had a but if we had more
than one one in any of these places
right over here then we might have had
to carry a one but we saw that when we
added when we added numbers in binary
but let's actually verify that this is
the number that we would expect it to be
remember this right over here is the
ones place so let's see this is ones
fours let me write it down this is ones
sorry ones twos
fours
eights
sixteens and thirty
so we have
so we have 132 so it's going to be 32
plus
1 8. once again we only have to do this
for ourselves because we're so used to
thinking in base 10. if you're thinking
in base 2 you'd say oh i know what this
number is and you would have some name
for it other probably different than 45
because 45 the name essentially is kind
of a base 10 name and we'd probably have
better names in terms of base 2. someone
actually should do that that would be a
fun that would be a fun you would call
well we would call this well that would
be that would be a fun project so you
have 32
plus 8
plus 4
plus
1. plus one which is indeed equal to
forty five